Speaker 1: Let's hear from some more people via
discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
Let's go to James from Texas.
If you're with us. James,
I would love to hear what's on your mind today.
Speaker 4: Yeah. Longtime fan. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Absolutely. All right. Longtime fan.
Thank you. When I first discovered you, it was a
interview with Peter Joseph. You remember Peter?
Speaker 1: Yes, I do. Those
eight guys. Movement guy?
Speaker 4: Yes. Excellent. So my
question to you is Peter Joseph,
Jack Fresco. These two individuals published
multiple films and Peter wrote a book and in
which they discussed the decline of society
based on our current economic model that
produces the negative results we're seeing now,
as in more mass shootings, more mental illness,
etc.. Do you believe that this is the case,
that the economic system we're in right now is
incapable of lasting and is going to
continue producing these negative?
Speaker 1: So incapable, incapable of lasting
is different then will continue to produce
negative externalities. So here this is a
huge topic, James, and a really great one.
I so let's see where to even start. Of course,
the economic system within which we live
influences our daily lives in many ways.
And in the same way that you can say, well,
the economic system allows us access to things we
like, cheap stuff, diversity of food, all these
different things, right? Things are things that
we think are good innovation, all the all these
things. It also creates negative issues. We
haven't yet fully dealt with the negative
externality of pollution that industry produces.
There's too much inequality. We have crime,
we have mental illness, a health care system
that's not working. All of these things right on
both sides of the ledger are partially a result of
the economic system. A lot of times sort of like
typical grad school master's level analysis kind
of end there. And they often end up at like, well,
I don't know, capitalism is the problem. And like,
I guess maybe for some people socialism would be
the solution or for people like me, it'd be social
democracy or whatever the case may be. I do think
that understated in some of those analyzes are
the impacts of what we know from sociology and
psychology and hard sciences and all these other
things. Now, those who say no, no, no, no, no,
the economic system influences all of that.
Our psychology and society is influenced by
the economic system. Yes, it is. But it's not only
influenced by that. So my view is I think people
like Peter Joseph and the late Jacques fresco have
very interesting things to say about the way that
many systems affect the way any one of us lives
day to day. What I don't like is when or I don't
agree with is when some people become too focused
solely on the economic analysis. And I don't think
we should minimize the economic analysis, but we
should make it much more robust than just that.
Speaker 4: And one more question.
Are you planning to do interviews
again? And would you consider having Peter
back on after psycho support comes out?
Speaker 1: We do like 15 interviews a month or
something like that. Ten interviews a month?
Yeah. So it's not it's not considering
we do interviews all the time and I would
be glad to have Peter back on the show. Sure.
Speaker 4: Excellent. I'm looking forward to it.
Speaker 1: All right, James from Texas, thank
you very much for the call. I appreciate that.